[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
brian laundry's parents are slammed with
a lawsuit by the family of gabby potito
the bombshell allegations made in the
court documents and evan rachel woods
speaks out for the first time about
alleged abuse at the hands of marilyn
manson i am very confident that i have
the truth on my side plus an ohio
officer is cleared in the death of makai
bryant but first a suspect linked to
multiple murders in washington d.c and
new york city we're talking about two
individuals that are homeless
the most vulnerable population
in the city right now we're live with
the latest developments law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
police believe a serial killer is on the
loose in new york city they have the
photo just not his name law and crime's
ancient levy is here with the details
internet
brian the heads of the nypd and the
washington d.c metro police say that
these shootings and killings are
definitely connected in that they
started in washington on march 3rd over
the weekend police in new york city
released surveillance images of a
shooter targeting two men as they slept
on the street in lower manhattan one man
in new york was shot in the arm and
survived a second died two of the three
victims in washington dc survived police
in both cities say the mo is the same
and that is why they believe all five
incidents are connected to the same
person
the
case is a clear and horrific
intentional act of taking the life
of someone that appears because he was
homeless
two individuals were shot
while sleeping on the streets
rewards are being offered they range
anywhere from ten thousand dollars to
twenty five thousand dollars for
information that leads to an arrest and
conviction of the shooter brian
joining us today is legal analyst
matthew mengino and terry austin as we
break down the string of homeless
shootings matthew with there being cases
in dc and new york city are we looking
at state and federal charges if so what
well you know typically brian when you
look at a homicide or an aggravated
assault that's usually something that is
the bailiwick so to speak of the state
courts and those would be state
prosecutions now if you can have
some
nexus
between these uh killings and interstate
commerce or some sort of interstate
criminal activity
then the united states the united states
attorney might be able to to come in and
prosecute these cases as federal
prosecutions but normally when we look
at something like homicide and we look
at something like aggravated assault
those are cases that are typically
the responsibility of the state courts
and local prosecutors yeah i can see the
fed saying hey you you travel state
lines with this intent to do this this
horrible act so maybe that's how they
catch him on that terry what is it going
to take to find this guy what do you
think the investigation will entail
well listen if we have both federal and
local authorities we will have an
abundance of resources but even just
from a local perspective we know that
the authorities are going to be looking
at those surveillance cameras in new
york city we have millions of cameras
around the city and i'm certain dc does
as well the authorities are also going
to try to talk to eyewitnesses there
might have been someone who saw what was
going on at the time maybe another
homeless person maybe someone who was
out on the street at that time in the
neighborhood and they're going to look
at social media perhaps this individual
said something on social media maybe
bragging about what was going on so
they're going to look everywhere they
possibly can to find out who did this
all right so angenette terry said state
and federal help in this case so let's
focus on the federal how's the federal
law enforcement assisting with the
investigation
well brian the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms better known as the atf is
assisting with the investigation and
they're doing that by using nibin that's
the national integrated ballistic
information network
there is information that is collected
about guns and shell casings that
information is analyzed uploaded to the
system and then they're able to compare
uh that you know information from the
shell casings found at these scenes to
data in that system to determine maybe
just maybe where that gun has been and
who owns it all right this investigation
is going to be ongoing and of course as
we get updates we'll make sure to bring
them to you here on lawn crime daily
also in new york a man is accused of
stabbing multiple employees at the
metropolitan museum of modern art after
his membership was revoked take a look
at this video people say gary cabana
stabbed two people when he was denied
entry the victims a 24 year old man and
woman were working behind the counter
when officials say cabana jumped over
the and stabbed both of them both
victims are in stable condition after
being taken to the hospital for
treatment cabana recounted the incident
on social media claiming he never caused
a disturbance and instead accused the
museum of framing him cabana claims he
has never been escorted out of the
museum and was blindsided when he
received the letter stating his
membership was revoked after the
incident the nypd held a news conference
explaining what happened
an individual entered the museum
attempted to gain entrance uh presenting
his membership card and was denied
entrance because his membership had
expired
his membership had expired as a result
of two incidents involving disorderly
conduct here at the museum on two
separate dates in recent days
he became
upset about not being allowed entrance
and then jumped over the reception desk
and proceeded to attack and stab
two employees of the museum multiple
times
those employees were stabbed
uh in the back
in the collar bone in the back of the
neck
and were rushed within minutes to
bellevue hospital where they received
immediate care
we are told that they're both going to
be okay
as of monday cabana has not been
arrested his last known place of
residence was a non-profit shelter for
the homeless and mentally ill a
spokesperson for the museum said the
moma will be open again to the public on
tuesday
still ahead on law and crime daily
singer marilyn manson files a defamation
lawsuit as actress evan rachel wood
doubles down on abuse allegations but
first the death of makai bryant what
decision a grand jury makes for the
columbus ohio police officer involved in
the shooting
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
ohio police officer will not be charged
nearly a year after the shooting death
of 16 year old black girl makai bryant
this comes as a grand jury determines
columbus ohio officer nicholas reardon
should not be indicted in brian's death
officials say reardon shot and killed
brian on april 20 of last year the same
day ex-cop derrick chovin was convicted
in the death of george floyd the
divisive case made national headlines
after brian's death body camera footage
shows weirdon shot bryant as she swung a
knife at another woman just seconds
after pushing a second woman to the
ground an autopsy later revealed bryant
was shot four times riordan says he
responded to a 911 call at brian's
foster home where someone was
threatening to stab other family members
last week special prosecutors announced
riordan would not face charges citing
that under ohio law deadly force is
justified when there's a threat of death
or serious injury to the officer or
someone else in a statement brian's
family has said in part quote there
should have been other non-deadly
options available to deal with this
situation
back to break down the no charges in the
fatal shooting is legal analyst matthew
mengino and terry austin terry what do
you think of the prosecution's reason
for no charges do you think this should
have gone to trial for the jury to
decide or was this the right choice
you know what brian that is an excellent
question in my opinion the jury really
could have decided this because as you
mentioned ohio law does allow for deadly
force if you reasonably believe that the
person posed an imminent threat of death
or serious bodily injury and he did
believe that so i think that was the
decision that the authorities made based
on the facts that they saw
but it is such a close call and in this
instance i think that the family deserve
to have a jury determine that so i think
that maybe it should have gone to that
jury and that the prosecution shouldn't
have closed that off no
no matthew judicial decisions
affect policing so how will this affect
police interactions in the future for
ohio
well i mean i think here uh you know the
the prosecutors they brought in special
prosecutors uh so they were independent
uh they brought it to a grand jury a
grand jury made a decision uh a
recommendation not to to file charges
you know i think what this gets down to
really is
well we see a lot of officer-involved
shootings we also have to recognize that
in the last uh couple of years that
police officers have been shot and
killed and killed in the line of duty at
numbers that are increasing uh each year
and we we need to build trust in the
community and and you know that has to
be has to come from an open dialogue
between police and community members uh
you know were
literally at war it seems uh on the
streets of many of our cities across the
country and we have to open a dialogue
to try to find solutions to these
problems that are resulting in in deaths
to civilians and deaths to police
officers as well yeah
well interesting the development in this
case there's nothing much after this as
there are no charges so we'll see if
anything changes or maybe meeting
policies as this story continues thank
you both
and in tennessee the second person in
charge in the death of an nba player
lorenzen wright is headed to trial jury
selection began monday in the case of
accused killer billy ray turner lorenzen
wright a former standout player at the
university of memphis who went on to
play for several teams in the nba was
killed in july 2010 his body was found
after his mother reported him missing
wright had been shot five times and left
in a wooded area near his mother's house
police had few leads for seven years
after the murder then in 2017
investigators arrested billy ray turner
after the gun used to kill wright was
found in a mississippi lake police
linked turner to wright's ex-girlfriend
shara turner and shara reportedly had a
relationship and attended church
together prosecutors led shera recruited
turner to kill wright for his life
insurance payout cheryl was also charged
in wright's death but took a plea deal
and pled guilty to facilitation of
murder last fall she is serving a
30-year sentence it isn't clear if she
will be called as a witness over the
next two weeks for turner's trial as
opening statements are set to begin this
week in total 15 jurors will be chosen
narrowed down from the more than 80
people who were called to serve
coming up on law and crime daily the
families of gabby petito and brian
laundry are headed to court as a new
lawsuit is filed plus evan rachel woods
speaks out for the first time since
naming singer marilyn manson as her
alleged abuser what she says about his
defamation lawsuit ahead
[Music]
welcome back we're hearing for the first
time from actress evan rachel wood as
she describes the alleged abuse she
suffered at the hands of her ex-fiance
singer marilyn manson the allegations
date back to the early 2000s when wood
says she was physically emotionally and
sexually abused by manson whose real
name is brian wagner
she came forward with the allegations
back in 2018 testifying before lawmakers
about the abuse including that she was
raped cut and forced to drink manson's
blood she publicly named manson as her
abuser just last year last month he
filed a lawsuit against wood claiming
defamation citing the allegations were
made under false pretenses including a
hoax letter from the fbi to convince
other women to come forward with sexual
abuse accusations wood spoke about the
allegations and abuse on abc's good
morning america
at the time you did not name the person
who you said had abused you why
i was too scared it was made very clear
to me that there would be retaliation
and to expose a person in power and who
is as high-profile as he is clearly is a
huge undertaking from what i can tell
he's alluding to the fact that maybe
this was just kinky sex
brian and i did not have a bdsm
relationship
we did not have kinky sex this is not a
sexual preference this is not
that's not what we're talking about here
what has not taken legal action against
manson but actors esme bianco and
mantin's former assistant have both sued
him based on sexual abuse allegations
legal analyst matthew mangino and
co-host terry austin are back as we
discuss the latest filings against
marilyn manson terry manson is
countersuing for defamation among other
things what damages is he looking for
and what does he have to do to prove his
claims
well he's suing primarily for that
defamation claim but also intentional
infliction of emotional distress which
is one of my favorite causes of action
because it basically can include almost
anything and the suit is against not
just wood but ashley gore who was
working with wood and they were trying
to pass legislation for abuse victims so
he sued both of them he's going to have
to prove that they made false statements
and that that was intentional on their
part it was knowingly made and he's
going to have to prove damages to his
reputation that's going to be difficult
because we know other people have
accused him of similar actions so he's
already got a damaged reputation for the
infliction of emotional distress he's
gonna have to show that he has damages
for that as well so he's got a long way
to go absolutely let's talk about one of
those cases matthew ashley walters
that's manson's assistant is suing for
sexual assault battery and harassment
but she said these memories were
repressed until a therapy session in
2020. does that create any legal hurdles
for her
well i you know i think it
it creates potential credibility hurdles
for her
there's no question that there's there's
um you know scientific evidence out
there that uh repressed memories uh can
in fact you know be triggered and come
back and and can result in uh
prosecutions or or uh you know
successful civil lawsuits uh but here
you know uh brian warner marilyn manson
um
his worst enemy may be himself because
he's bragged about
this bad girl's room the rape room and
other things like that and and those
things his own words uh may be his worst
enemy in these suits and uh
you know the repressed memory may have
an impact but i i think it could be
enough to carry the day yeah especially
because there's multiple alleged victims
in this case all kind of saying the same
thing we'll see how this and other cases
play out from here on law and crime
daily we'll make sure to give you those
updates
also in celebrity legal news the defense
attorneys for actor jesse smollette file
an emergency motion to pause his
sentence and grant bond this comes less
than one week after smallett was
sentenced to 150 days in jail to be
served at chicago's infamous cook county
jail along with time behind bars
smallett was also sentenced to 30 months
felony probation 120 000 in restitution
and 25 thousand dollar fine after an
illinois jury found him guilty of
reporting a false hate crime back in
2019. at last thursday's sentencing
smollette loudly professed to judge
james lynn
he was not suicidal the following day
smaller attorneys filed an emergency
injunction saying smollett is the target
of online threats and is in danger of
physical harm
when we come back the family of gabby
potido points the finger at brian
laundry's parents why they say that
laundry's parents knew about gabby
patino's death before she was reported
missing
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
ar-15 rifle kyle rent used to shoot
three people has been destroyed by the
wisconsin state crime lab this comes
just four months after rent house was
acquitted on all accounts in connection
to the kenosha wisconsin riots of august
2020. law and crime daily brought you
gavel gavel coverage of the trial where
reign house was charged in the shooting
deaths of joseph rosenbaum anthony
hoover and injury of gage grokowskis
as rittenhouse was 17 years old at the
time of the shooting friend dominic
black purchased the weapon for him in an
interview earlier this year rinhaus's
attorney mark richards explained why his
client wanted the weapon destroyed
can you explain why kyle retinas was so
insistent about destroying or having
that gun destroyed what was his
reasoning because
there was dual claims to the gun
and
we did not want the gun being returned
to dominic black and then having him
sell it as kyle rittenhouse has done
like
have happened in other famous cases
we didn't think anybody should profit
from it and we wanted it destroyed
and the family of gabby petito now
claims brian laundry's parents knew
their daughter was murdered and were
working to help him leave the country
this has petito's parents slam chris and
roberto laundry with a civil lawsuit the
lawsuit says laundry told his parents
about petito's murder in late august of
last year and that they later helped
conceal his location before he went
missing gabby pitido made national
headlines last fall after she was
reported missing in early september her
family told officials she had been on a
cross-country road shit with her fiance
brian laundry potato's body was later
found in grand teton national park her
cause of death was ruled to be
strangulation after a weeks-long
man-hunt laundry's remains were
discovered in a florida reserve
authorities determined he died by
suicide along with his remains
investigators found a written confession
where laundry admitted to killing potito
according to court documents patito's
parents are now seeking more than thirty
thousand dollars in damages from the
laundry family
matthew this seems a little confusing if
the petito family has information that
laundries that the laundry sorry knew
gabby was murdered shouldn't we also be
seeing criminal charges too
well that's a good question um you know
this this civil suit alleges in in in
the complaint uh that the the laundry uh
laundry family refused to talk with the
police and talk with the petito family
you know after um their son came home
so by its very allegations it's
suggesting that they they weren't giving
any misleading information they weren't
lying they just were refusing to talk to
him and i think in this civil suit uh
they have a duty
uh to prove that there was some
responsibility on the part of the
laundry to divulge information about
their son or turn over information about
his whereabouts uh you know he was a a
person of interest for the most part uh
while this was going on so so they're
going to have a tough time showing that
responsibility um with regard to their
conduct and then with regard to criminal
charges unless they can show maybe that
they were trying to get their son out of
the country the launchers are trying to
get their sign out of the country before
his suicide that might lead uh to to
some um
terry quickly about the civil case how
strong is that um is that an actual
claim they can make
yeah actually let me just add while i
always agree with matthew i think here
they have a claim and they could prove
it because there was mental suffering
all right we'll see how it plays out
then well thank you for joining us here
at law and crime daily always appreciate
it and we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you